what started as protests over offensive
Halloween costumes and racial
insensitivity at Yale and Missouri has
spread to other campuses with thousands
of student protesters demanding an end
to what they see as systemic racism on
campus at Mizzou a student's hunger
strike over racism and an unprecedented
football team boycott of future games
led to President Tim Wolfe's resignation
protesters have succeeded in ousting
administrators at other campuses these
developments prove that student
activists have plenty of institutional
power and we ought to support their
right to flex their muscles and advocate
for the changes they want unfortunately
a lot of these student activists have
the First Amendment in their crosshairs
you're insulting me and what they need
right now would you go to be alone at
Amherst students demanded the censorship
of pro free speech flyers at Yale
students wanted the firing of officials
who reaffirmed the right to wear
offensive Halloween costumes and at both
Missouri in the University of Chicago
demonstrators physically prevented
journalists from talking to activists
students one of these sensors was a
professor of journalism student
activists say they want their campuses
to become safe spaces but they're
conflating two very different kinds of
safety of course students have the right
to physical safety but too many students
wrongly believe this includes emotional
safety free speech isn't an obstacle
that prevents radical activists from
getting what they want it's a necessary
condition for them to promote their
ideas students should fight racism and
inequality on college campuses and
they'll actually need free speech to do
that